[Musique]
c'est un bâtiment emblématique de la
capitale comtoise pendant cinq décennies
les touristes sont entrés si quelques
minutes à la recherche d'une information
en 2019 l'office de tourisme a changé
d'adressé et le bâtiment a été racheté
par jocelyn gelé l'homme d'affaires
bisontin déjà propriétaires dans le jura
du château de germigney décide d'en
faire un restaurant gastronomique et son
cahier des charges est strict j'ai voulu
vraiment mettre tout le savoir faire
puisqu'ils étaient envisageables à
besançon pour réaliser dans le sol yeux
pourquoi des locaux pourquoi parce que
j'aime ma région je me ville on a tout
pour rayonner donc
c'est pour la mettre en avant tous ces
talents qui sont là et sans forcément
aller chercher plus loin ils sont ici et
on arnaque on a construit cette équipe
pour pour faire ces lieux la décoration
intérieure a été confiée au designer
bisontin d'hybrides ils ont dû
s'approprier ce lieu tout de verre et
d'alu conçu par michel de mange
architecte lui aussi il a à la fois sa
propre histoire qu'il a 2 69 de plan
libre magique sur le parc
et puis sur l'inspiration qu'on y
retrouve deux mises en déroute du
pavillon de barcelone de 29
donc on était extrêmement intimider
respectueux par forcément par part ça et
on a essayé de se glisser dans cette
boîte magnifique c'est exceptionnel
comme le lieu les c'est en même temps je
trouve quelque chose qui relie hybride
dans son adn d'une part l'ancrage à la
nature le besoin impérieux de faire
rentrer la nature à l'intérieur et en
même temps l'ancrage artistique et
culturelle le ch était la sommelière eux
aussi viennent d'ici formé au lycée
hôtelier de poligny il travaillait dans
un trois étoiles français d'hong kong
quand jocelyn jeu l'aider à solliciter
défis relevés et respect de la charte
jusque dans l'assiette on ne va pas se
restreindre à un ancrage local de 200
kilomètres comme ça se fait de plus en
plus moi j'ai quand même envie d'avoir
des poissons de mer donc je obligé
d'aller en bretagne on a des pêcheurs
breton
si j'ai des produits régionaux français
je vais les juges en france et on va
essayer de trouver tout ce qui se fait
de mieux en local et par contre ici j'ai
pas le choix d'un j'irai ailleurs d'ici
trois semaines l'établissement ouvrira
un deuxième espace au rez-de-chaussée du
bâtiment
le café du parc
[Musique]